on continue à parler avec vous Karim et
yaoui bonjour les alliés occidentaux du
président ukrainien volodières zenens
qui est aussi pointe du doigt la Russie
c'est vrai que même s'il n'y a pas de
preuve absolue tout semble désigner la
Russie dans cette affaire puisque les
premiers éléments semblent à créditer le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu de frappe
extérieur notamment de missiles ou
d'obus et encore il aurait fallu
beaucoup d'obus pour endommager ce
barrage les premiers éléments semblent à
créditer plutôt la thèse d'une implosion
ou d'une explosion depuis l'intérieur du
barrage en se souvient aussi queenski
avait déjà évoqué cette hypothèse il y a
de longs mois déjà en expliquant que les
Russes avaient placé des explosifs à
l'intérieur du barrage et qu'il menaçait
de le faire sauter il y a aussi des
précédents ce n'est pas une stratégie
inédite du côté des Russes il y a
quelques mois du côté de qui
Ivry ils avaient sauté un barrage pour
tenter indiquer l'avancée des troupes
ukrainiennes qui allaient très
rapidement en direction de Carson une
ville qui a été par la suite reprise par
les par les Ukrainiens donc tout semble
plutôt pointé du doigt les Russes pour
qui il y a évidemment un avantage
stratégique à faire sauter ce barrage
pour tenter de rendre plus difficile
cette fameuse contre-offensive
ukrainienne dont on parle tant alors on
va peut-être tout de même voir une carte
où on voit la Crimée mais aussi
cette ce ravitaillement en eau qui est
permis grâce à cette à ce barrage
puisque
l'argument des Russes c'est de dire que
ce sont les Ukrainiens qui ont voulu
couper l'alimentation en eau de la
péninsule de Crimée qui a été envahi par
les Russes en 2014 mais cet argument est
relativement faible par rapport aux
avantages que pourrait tirer les Russes
de cette de cette explosion de ce
barrage clairement Kar la destruction
partielle de ce barrage ça risque
d'avoir des conséquences sur la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne désirent d'ailleurs
volodymer Zelinski estimait que Moscou
avait saboté cette infrastructure pour
ralentir l'offensive de l'armée
ukrainienne exactement mais en même
temps ce même volo du meilleur Zelinski
explique que ça n'aura pas d'impact sur
l'avancée des
Ukrainiens et sur cette contre-offensive
en réalité tout de même c'était un axe
qui aurait pu être utilisé par l'armée
ukrainienne puisque ce barrage en haut
de ce barrage il y avait un axe routier
qui aurait pu permettre d'avancer
notamment en direction de de la Crimée
mais c'est vrai que ce n'est qu'un point
du front il y a 1000 km de front on va
découvrir une carte de ce de ce front
qui c'est un petit peu figé ces derniers
mois mais où il y a tout de même une
activité intense côté
ukrainien notamment du côté de la ville
martyr de darkmouth ont découvert donc
cette carte
Carson ici barthout par ici ou les ou
les Ukrainiens redouble des forts ils
occupent des positions en hauteur sur la
ville de darkmouth et font reculer peu à
peu les Russes puisqu'ils ont reculé
d'une localité aux abords de barmouth
alors ça n'aura peut-être pas d'impact
sur l'ensemble du front mais tout de
même ça contrarie les projets
Ukrainiens des Ukrainiens qui restent
extrêmement discret sur le calendrier
sur la méthode ils veulent qu'on ne
parle pas trop de cette contre-offensive
il multiplie tout de même les opérations
les opérations coup de poing en quelque
sorte pour tenter d'identifier peut-être
les points faibles sur cette ligne de
front et y engagé de façon plus
abondante abondante leur troupes alors
pour revenir à cette à cette à cette
explosion de ce de ce barrage côté russe
il y a aussi évidemment un intérêt tout
particulier c'est peut-être celui de
détourner les regards qui étaient en
train de se figer sur les difficultés
russes puisque de plus en plus
d'attaques se font directement sur le
territoire russe notamment du côté de
Belgorod ou même encore ces drones qui
sont arrivés jusqu'à la capitale et un
certain nombre de dissensions à
l'intérieur des troupes russes entre les
hommes de Prigogine et l'armée russe et
évidemment il y a une volonté de créer
un effet de sidération au sein de la
population
ukrainienne avec cette catastrophe hors
norme merci beaucoup